une journée placée sous le signe du
business et de l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est le principe de la 5e édition des
smart days organisés par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des yvelines
au sein du siège de bouygues
construction à guyancourt mais je pense
que ça thème intéressant important parce
qu'il devient mature pour les
entreprises
l'intelligence artificielle est un peu
partout dans la vie dans les domaines
d'activité et c'est important aussi
d'apporter des éléments aux entreprises
du territoire sur l'intelligence
artificielle grands comptes pme et
start-up étaient présents pour faire
découvrir leurs technologies innovantes
mais aussi renforcer leurs réseaux
depuis six ans cette entreprise
yvelinois s'est spécialisé dans
l'intelligence artificielle pour la
relation client fait on va être capable
de créer des robots conversationnel donc
cessons des robots qui vont être
capables de comprendre des requêtes
d'humains et d'y répondre
automatiquement
donc si vous avez un problème par
exemple à 4 heures du matin mais en fait
vous allez pouvoir interagir avec un
robot concessionnels parce que lui il
est capable de vous répondre tout de
suite de son côté cette entreprise
toulousaine soutenu financièrement par
bouygues construction a développé des
solutions d'assistance vocale au
technicien présente dans cet espace
d'exposition elle est à la recherche de
nouveaux clients des contacts avec des
grosses le des roses industriels ou des
entreprises de taille intermédiaire qui
pourrait avoir des besoins de ce type de
technologie dont condé technicien qui
des techniciens qui travaillent à partir
de papiers ou à partir de documents qui
sont un peu complexe et où notre
assistant pour aider aider à mieux
travailler
une cinquième édition qui a vu sa
fréquentation augmenter par rapport à
l'année dernière avec près de 600
personnes inscrites